[Musique]
vous croyez pouvoir me guérir jean tu
n'es pas malade
l'esprit est une chose fragile
le moindre petit choc peut lui faire
prendre la mauvaise direction
charles qu'est ce que tu as fait devait
la stabiliser je les protéger
de la vérité
et bien un autre mot pour ça je suis
venu chercher des réponses à mes
questions
tu pense ne pas être à ta place ici fini
ils sont incapables de comprendre ce que
tu es
se transformer
pourquoi ce ne sont pas des réponses que
tu cherches tu es venu chercher une
autorisation
[Musique]
elle n'est que fureur douleur et tout
explose en même temps j ne se contrôle
plus mais elle reste notre ami c'est un
faux tchad le monde va basculer
je suis désolé de n'avoir rien fait
avant tu es toujours désolé chat puis
toujours tu te justifie et ça
n'intéresse plus personne
il ya encore de l'espoir
ne faites pas ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les ont raison ne cravate
j'ai vu le ballon
et je le vois maintenant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu me fais confiance
oui pourquoi alors bougez surtout pas
c'est vrai ce qu'on dit sur vous vous
êtes le meilleur des gardes du corps
vous pouvez tirer simba au même endroit
comme craignez personne considérée ni
comme celui à qui on fait appel d'un des
leurs
vraiment pas de quoi tu parles
excuse moi de dire
ça casse
[Applaudissements]
bruxelles sûr pas du tout ce truc là bas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon j'ai trouvé une voiture abo
cya
[Musique]
bumblebee
je m'appelle charlie white fun j'ai 18
ans aujourd'hui en fait la coccinelle
est à vendre
elle est à toi joyeuse anniversaire
[Musique]
c'est pas vrai t'es quoi toi
et tu sais pas d'où ils sortent vraiment
pas vraiment parlé
waouh je t'explique
les gens peuvent être horrible avec ce
qu'ils ne comprennent pas non la seule
personne qui ait le droit de te voir
témoin ok c'est bon c'est bon là c'est
bon merci
une guerre fait rage sur notre planète
si on ne retrouve pas ce criminel notre
guerre deviendra la vôtre enfin
quelqu'un qui peut aider à une famille
ok moi
il faut venir une armée
j'ai pu voir ce que sont réellement ces
choses
bumblebee il n'y a qu'un moyen de mettre
un terme ce conflit
tu dois protéger la terre et ses
habitants
c'est le seul moyen
je suis là pour toi
je n'abandonne pas
je vais faire tuer
la seule chose qui m'intéresse et la
vengeance
[Musique]
vers la guerre à toutes ces ordures qui
colle à la peau
[Applaudissements]
tu l'aimés prisme tu vaux pas mieux
qu'eux
[Musique]
tu es l'un d'eux
next bagnard obsédé par l'idée de se
racheter une place dans la société
je voulais divy doc
ces deux grands projets pour vous
[Musique]
oui
et ouais
à l'automate et maman je suis très fier
d'eux
[Musique]
le risque c'est les sorties extra
véhicule du sein en gardant ses 454
[Musique]
oh
oui
[Musique]
m
ça c'est du passé maintenant si tu meurs
[Musique]